Thomas pynchon,
sprawling,
epic,
postmodern novel gravity's Rainbow.
There's a sequence in which the main
character is interrogated by the US
government under the influence of Sodium
Amatol,
commonly called truth serum.
The writing slips into several dreamlike
rips on language.
In one,
a telegram from Wisconsin launches the
main character into an obsessive
meditation on the possible constructions
of a six word sequence.
You never did the Kenosha kid.
As more and more examples are presented
each with different punctuations,
we become aware of a key postmodern
truth that words can point toward
reality,
but they can never get there.
They always mean different things in
different contexts,
but just how many different contexts are
there will pinch in,
only gives us seven.
There are far too many punctuation marks
and emphases,
far too many combinations for a single
writer to catalog them all besides in
the aesthetic universe of the novel.
Cataloging them all would be exhaustive
and redundant.
Enter the Internet and a man named
Darrius Kazimir.
Hi everybody.
He makes what he likes to call weird
Internet stuff.
I make what I like to call weird
Internet stuff,
which I recently come to accept is
Internet art.
Last year,
Darrius made a twitter Bot that did what
the writer,
Thomas Pynchon can't ever do.
It automatically generates a different
construction of the.
You never did the Kenosha kids sequence
every two hours,
and as of this video,
the account has already tweeted 8,600
times and with the number of
permutations possible could continue for
years without exhausting every one go
there sometime.
Try reading a few outloud.
The effect of pensions language
experiment is compounded,
updated the truth that wants to
communicate is received in a new way,
and the exhaustive list that would have
been inappropriate in a book is made
novel and strangely vital in this new
form.
I think what this shows us is that the
aesthetics of Internet art of art made
with and for and on,
the Internet won't conform to any that
we've known before and that's fitting
because a lot of internet artists made
unlike any art that came before it.
Because Amy's twitter bots aren't made
with paint brushes or musical
instruments.
They're made with algorithms with code.
This is what the Kenosha kid twitter Bot
really looks like.
Is there any beauty in that,
but what about this box?
No,
it's just a set of instructions.
Here's what those instructions do.
This programming rules perform a simple
task.
They access the Texas Department of
criminal justice and pull from the
public.
Last word statements of death row
inmates.
Any sentence that contains the word
love.
This art piece isn't out to make an
overtly political statement on capital
punishment,
like all good art.
This project organizes elements in the
world around it to help an audience see
and feel in a new way.
The difference is that the World Kazemi
is commenting on it isn't the physical
world not really.
It's the digital world,
the world of the Internet,
and indeed much of our digital internet
art is focused on itself on the visible
and more importantly invisible aspects
of a network that's all around us.
Computation is now everywhere.
It is lead of everything and we are
living inside that computer as well.
That's James Bridle,
a critic and digital artists.
Bridal did a project recently called
Rainbow planes,
a project that started when he noticed
some odd artifacts from google earth of
planes with rainbow after images.
It's a glitch.
Um,
but like all true glitches,
it's not just a mistake,
um,
it's kind of an opportunity to look
through into the underlying systems that
produce this image.
In this case,
it shows us that the satellites
composing these images aren't using
cameras,
but rather are collecting data from a
broad swath of the electromagnetic
spectrum and they record red,
green and blue separately when they,
when they make these data images.
And so occasionally you find within
satellite images these artifacts which
are produced by fast moving objects,
bridals digital art wants to help us see
the way technology sees us,
how hugely powerful systems have moved
slowly into our lives without much
protest.
These systems are not like us.
We see with eyes,
they see with data,
we think with mines,
they think with algorithms aren't like
this shows us that our increasing
dependence on sophisticated technologies
comes at the cost of substituting our
values and our motives for theirs.
So maybe the aesthetic value of Internet
art is measured by its ability to help
us see the internet,
just as a novel can help us see language
or an image can help us see reality.
That's just an idea and I can't say how
valid it is for you,
but I think we do have to try to develop
an aesthetic for this new digital art,
a way by which we can determine which of
it is good,
which of it is crap in which we consider
truly essential because what we think is
great art speaks ultimately to what we
think is valuable in culture and
articulating our values about the
internet,
the global network in the years before
it consumes everything might just be the
most important thing.
Our generation.
Good effort to.
Hey everybody,
thanks for watching.
Getting this in just before sunset here,
welcome to 2016.
You want to help me out in 2016,
you can pledge a dollar or $3 per video
by clicking right below here and going
to my patrion page.
That money will go toward making 50 new
videos for you guys this year.
Just an exciting prospect to make what I
hope is content unique to youtube and
the Internet.
Um,
so thank you guys again.
I will see you all next Wednesday.